yep welcome home thank you for a big if
you want to change anything that's fine
just run it by me first if you could let
me super cool you know we're work with
each other
[ __ ] seems like you like that do you
go buy anything for short or even for
long should I call you King Charles
Queen Charles I like to just keep it
loose in this house there's no wrong way
to sit on a couch
Chloe I kind of like the sound of that
Chloe it is
it's like good soccer practice - I'm
fine I'm fine
you got to be careful this end of the
piano is kind of my zone that's actually
really beautiful the further I go down
there just the scarier it gets this is
one of the eyes of a robot that I killed
I'm kidding
yeah see yeah babies were such a
confusing time but so much was happening
musically I'm singing job Mandy's got
really grungy I put a lot of work into
this guy presenting it tomorrow so keep
your paws crossed
are you hungry I'm starving what are you
supposed to eat oh there's even food
rest for puppies that's you puppy food
or baby dog here's your ball oh oh
you're fine with it on the ground
someone's in here uh this is your
bathroom okay do you need me not to
watch all that go now okay
looks like dog food you should enjoy man
a puppy as long as you can
you're still there Chloe that's whatever
you're doing is loud I'm trying to sleep
are you trying to dig a hole I need I
just need some space I know you didn't
mean I I didn't mean to freak out like
that you hungry I'm gonna get some
breakfast
nice
look this is gonna work out great